[Music]
and welcome to Friday sweet potato pie
this week we're gonna do another
business everything
the show where I [ __ ] myself on for you
bros entertainment let's do it try to
lick your nipple while jumping on one
leg why am i nipples so far away it's
this give us a good life less than
speech don't be a salad be the best
goddamn broccoli you could ever be this
is everything drink a glass of water
upside down do your best impression of
Magikarp
Pierce's deputies reenact candles you
shall not pass see you shall not pass
be careful run you fools
[Music]
I am back Gandalf
how did you have a wither everything wax
your chest am I gonna regret this
[Laughter]
can we take it off without turning to a
fire truck and put out a fire tell the
girls how much you love them ah works
for Maya
[Music]
I'd say about 538 too much alright I
hope you brothers enjoy this episode of
business everything you can see my nose
hopefuls actually off on a Friday I
don't really know yet I just realized
that was kind of early on the last time
we actually hit 7 million brothers
yesterday double yesterday the day after
smart day after the day that came I have
no words to describe like how
overwhelming it is to imagine that 7
million billion
something I've been noticing a lot of a
lot of increase in positivity and
feedback make me gross and that's really
what actually means something 7 million
that's amazing but it's just a number
and I care more about the support I get
from you bro listen I noticed a lot more
of that lately and it just that's what
really makes me happy so thank you for
Bros for that stay awesome we're gonna
end it actually all we do with the
[ __ ] brofist anyway here it comes
stay awesome so yeah ii my watch is a
penis what do you know about life